what's happening there people we're
gonna watch ourselves some gravity falls
today what episode is this john it's
episode 17. guys if you can follow us at
patreon full of reaction watch alongs we
think of the time go for gravity falls
are over there thanks to all who have
followed us so far and becomes super
jacks but if you can't do that the least
you can do is leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated subscribe and
click the notification bell to get
notified when our next reaction for
gravity falls is up and as always them
boys at prepper you are mabel and dipper
and grunkle stan let's get to it
[Music]
let's talk about why i'm doing this
dance okay
oh no she got into the smile dip again
1000 it's because today is the greatest
day of my life mac ow june times is
playing at the gravity falls civic
center in buffet
ugh several times nice
we're not threatening
huh where's lens flare they're just a
manufactured product of the bloated
corporate music industry there's
probably a machine that mass produces
them oh or maybe the boys are grown from
pods
mabel's got backup hey guys
girls i know right
i'm okay oh
boy oh boy
nothing's gonna go wrong today it's
funny having just watched turning red
which dealt with boy vance tune was also
from disney oh good that's what disney's
doing they explore generational trauma
and boy bands and generational trauma
caused by boy bands tonight we're gonna
meet craig g greggy c leggy p chubby z
and deep chris deep chris will fall in
love with us why wouldn't they
oh my god that's gross but they probably
would like that i'm not sure this
relationship's working maybe i should
see other people
like tipper baby dipper before you do
anything crazy i i uh i want you to hear
this
i hope this works the necronomicon just
listen to this song and you'll be
hypnotized
oh my god he's actually hypnotizing you
know maybe i was being a little hasty
i'll give you another chance yes all
right
let me go grab my coat all right rob
fight him what the heck are you up to
it's called romance kid something you'd
never understand [ __ ] robbie guys
the weirdest thing just happened i think
robbie might be hypnotizing wendy with
his music oh dipper girls just like
musicians you'll understand when you're
old get it mabel girls mature faster
than guys right grinda
this is grunda time
very mature tickets please
too late girls the show's sold out oh
no
no
i welcome you death steal a credit hard
and go on stubhub robbie might be
brainwashing wendy with music i've seen
this before her name was carla mccorkle
carla hot pants mccorkle
grunkle hunk our favorite 50s themed
1970s diner
huncle stan carla's hot pants turned
into bell-bottoms before i even knew
what happened oh
my memories get a little hallucination-y
at the end
boy believe my theory you're darn right
i do and we're gonna get to the bottom
of it oh
[Music]
[Applause]
i love you deep chris i love you dave
chris
he was talking to me
[Applause]
hello several times
oh god
[Music]
are mass produced
this is fun that is one big hamster tube
someone's coming
you barely even sold out the arena
indeed chris you call that a pout
except you leggy p you really on point
tonight here you go gorgeous
you can always be replaced by your
brothers dance for me child
dance my throat is killing me can
someone get me a lemon in water
they can totally get out of those cages
she's a lady don't disrespect her bro no
disrespect my bad
chubby z let's calm this boo by posing
for a poster style
[Music]
mr brassman's our producer yo he
genetically engineered us to be the
perfect boy band gee but he keeps us in
cages that junk is straight brutal girl
[Laughter]
yo i heard tell about these things
called trees i don't know what they are
but i want to kiss one but we can't
disobey mr bratsman he says he loves him
ah
me and my friends can help you escape
music has subliminal mind control hidden
in it all the time even the music i play
in the gift shop has subtle hidden
messages
[Music]
oh yeah if you want to hear the mind
controlling messages you gotta slow down
the record give me that lp
oh yeah
right we're doing something wrong here
but i can't put my finger on it
it's like one of those old playstation
discs
[Music]
those three girls carried them your tour
bus is really strange mabel girl where
the feeding tube's at yo what up girl
[Laughter]
it's your producer i can't believe those
boys escaped from their cage you there i
found this trail oh
have you seen any perfect boys around
here only when i look in the mirror up
top
shoo shoo
don't worry guys he has to give up
eventually hey in the meantime you could
stay here with us
2013.
we have our very own pet boy band that
we can do whatever we want no bueno
[Music]
teach them to be alive just just a few
more minutes but
curry bae you drunk on the boy band
mabel prepare to have your mind blown
spit take here i come
that's not spit worthy what gives what
that is
it's the case what's up junior try to
come up with an equation to make girls
like you
ready to go to lookout point
am i later dorks catch you on the rewind
playing backwards back
masking soon you are now under my
control
oh no i gotta save wendy finally a good
reason to punch a teenager in the face
let's roll there's many good reasons
finally got them to sleep poor greggy
see he tried to eat a tape dispenser i
think this is food dog
he was pulled over tonight for not
having a rear license plate i'm telling
you the goat took it that's what they
all say oh jail awaiting trial
recovering from a beatdown
that's so fast they're not going
anywhere
it's the movie misery if you love them
you just set them free never every boy i
love this summer has left me and i'm not
gonna let it happen again candy we gotta
get past mabel she's gone boy crazy oh
no
herkman brats man is in jail is that
true mabel dog uh no you can't listen to
her mabel's all girl girl several times
yes
[Laughter]
mabel's gone matter with power save
yourself several times you are better
off with your producer no i don't think
that's the word i said let's get aboard
the brain train
you're a tyrant mabel nate didn't show
up so i i guess it's just you and me
this isn't what i was planning at all
wow
wendy stop
robbie's been lying to you
dipper kid mr pines that's mr pines to
you
bible girl we dreamed of being
[Music]
baby i promise i don't know anything
about those messages in fact i didn't
even write that song i ripped it off
some other band so we're all good stupid
you said you wrote that song for me and
i actually thought it was sweet big liar
i know i know i lie about a lot of stuff
like using your makeup and fighting a
bear although no uh it's over robbie
we're through what wendy goodbye
we won uh for every guy whose hands are
too weak or fat to play a musical
instrument now that your night is free
me and uncle sam were thinking maybe
bowling what is wrong with guys you only
think about yourselves all of you should
just leave me alone i don't like the way
this makes me feel any better the
apocalypse is coming soon bury your
goals
what's going on mabel girl you said you
had something you wanted to show us or
some deal yep then
yo dog who is this big round bright fool
that fool's making my eyes burn straight
painful i'm gonna steer that fool down
oh yeah go for it you got this what's
this big green mess that's nature deep
chris
the re free you're free it means you can
skedaddle
now go go
they're gonna die out there get out of
here before i change my mind
they're gonna die mabel or at least go
blind you think she'll ever forgive me i
bet she will and until then you can
always go bowling with me thanks grunkle
stan oh something rooting through our
trash
hey
get out of here
darn beautiful men always eating eating
out of my trash
[Laughter]
we're not threatening girl yeah
get that tree
[Music]
oh god
what's he gonna do that tree is sexy
sexy oh god
uh funniest joke was at the end
johnny do your thing
i
thought this was a fun and enjoyable
episode i feel like uh you know
you know it's coming that there's
something's gonna be
scientifically mad cap with the boy band
but uh you know i mean even though it's
well tread territory at this point in
cartoons and whatnot i got a kick out of
it
uh but i also got a kick out of the
bonding
experience between dipper and stan
weirdly enough that those last moments
were kind of like oh that's kind of nice
you know stan's always a grouch you know
he's always uh kind of at odds with
everybody it's part of the humor of his
character so to see him and dip her at a
place where dipper's feeling kind of
crestfallen and you know stan's like hey
kid you're gonna be all right you know
this is uh this is a situation a lot of
young guys land themselves in when
they're you know blinded by love and
affection and whatnot and uh hey you can
come bowling with me that warmed my
heart up you know and uh usually stan is
yeah like a good funny
like zany character and it was nice to
have a moment of of male bonding
together offsetting the
you know obsessive
beautiful male storyline taking place on
the a plot uh yeah and it was cool
because like the last couple
of episodes i feel like not that you
know i i prefer it one way over the
other but i feel like things have been
kind of unified whereas this one was
like okay there's a definite dipper
story there's definite mabel story and
both of them have to do
with different takes on brainwashing
through music or at least the sort of
intoxication
and uh you know sort of mental clouding
that can you know happen as a result of
the right sounds pointed at the right
person
so uh yeah i liked this episode it was
pretty fun and just all the different uh
same but slightly
alternate personalities of the boy bands
that definitely made me chuckle
and uh yeah reminded me of uh
documentary i saw about the
the horrible
guy who put the backstreet boys and sync
and stuff together and all the abuses
that that man perpetrated so i'm glad
their guy went to jail
because uh yeah they're probably better
off that way what do you think
wow you must be quite passionate about
that one i'm so
passionate
uh yeah i mean i thought this one was
fine i i didn't
love this one like i've been loving
gravity falls thus far uh it's
this was like uh
this plot about the boy band thing is uh
like the kind of ribbing they do on boy
bands
is is like yeah i've seen variations of
this joke done many times i do like that
they went like very literal with it
making them these actual things that are
genetic that are like produced in a lab
i think is really funny and there were
some jokes with them that i thought were
really funny and i think the there is
some creativity to be had especially
with the actual development of the of
the music them writing their own songs
though
no that's a no-no totally implausible
implausible they don't do that 99 of the
time and yeah man boy bands are like
freaking awful for a lot of people you
know
it's fun learning about like k-pop bands
versus like 90s bands and stuff like
that i don't know how much the rules and
all that has changed with the moral
ethics but i know someone who used to be
in a boy band actually and yeah they are
just awful experiences and they really
do make you these these products these
machines that you can obviously see even
if you don't do research it's really
apparent so i liked seeing them take
that in a very literal form and making
fun of that um
but there was something about it that
just felt like ah i think there was
still something a little bit more
inventive that gravity falls would have
done absolutely and that wasn't quite
hitting the mark that a lot of the jokes
were a little bit more of the obvious
like they're all dummies you know
they're all dummy robots
where i i don't really know what it
would be that would make it more unique
but i i feel like you could have gone
into like
this is this is one iteration of the
manufactured clone boy band there's got
to be like a secret cabal of like you
know people that's where my mind went is
like maybe this producer guy is part of
some kind of illuminati-esque
organization that you know cranks these
out all over the world you know
i still like that they made the a and b
storyline like you were talking about
music but also
how they both were
about
possession and obsession
and
how trying to control someone else's
life is not good
and i thought that was a cool way to
like correlate the two and yeah uncle
sam and dipper bonding together was
really delightful i liked that story
more even though it was featured way
less i i thought that story was much
better because i can relate because i'm
a guy i can't relate with a girl in boy
pants but that's the reason why nah it's
i thought it was still amusing but i
still think that that storyline had more
of the things that i like about gravity
falls you know more even something that
was like the hypnosis angle that we've
seen done with music before that's like
a
thing that i think has been done like
spy movies too so i i enjoyed that side
of it and it was something more fresh
for gravity falls and i also
liked the way it ended on a note with
wendy that wasn't
like a win at all like it wasn't
something positive i thought they
actually had kind of a real moment of
the way she reacted to dipper just
trying to
bring her back on his side and just keep
going with the fun and not taking a
moment to understand the pain she must
be going through at that moment to
feeling hurt and betrayed
so having a little bit more of that
nuance i thought was actually refreshing
for this show to end on a note that just
wasn't funny uh but you know it's still
funny it's still amusing wasn't terrible
wasn't bad yeah i just think that it's
like bottom tier of the episodes
especially in like the last chunk that
we've seen thus far but still did a good
job and uh yeah i won't forget it and
also i might be a little bit burnt out
from the boy band joke especially
literally after watching tourney red
which had dealt so much with a
boy band you make fun of so well yeah
yeah i i would have to agree as much as
i had fun with this it that is totally
like something where i thought they
could have gone
further or more unique because it is
such well trod chardon territory now and
so many other comics and cartoons and
shows have done it and it didn't feel
conceptually
like a big leap it more felt like oh
this is something that shows do so we'll
do this you know yeah so there's always
a little bit of an extra nudge i thought
it could have gone even with mabel going
like crazy and possessive i thought they
could have made the hygiene go a little
bit darker without being too dark for
disney but just a little bit darker a
little bit dark comedy can go a long way
um
but yeah guys what do you think about
the episode leave your thoughts down
below keep a lookout for our next
gravity falls reaction got a whole
playlist here thanks for being here
catch the full length of patreon see you
guys soon wait we should
ricardo martinez hey you're here at the
end of the month you just squeezed in
and i recognize your name we've seen you
in the ten dollar tier so welcome
welcome to the inner sanctum of the real
rejects my friend where all the secrets
will now be revealed you will be brought
in and briefed you're gonna have to sign
a lot of mdas and whatnot because we
have a whole factory of greg's and
john's back here just ready to be
cranked out to make reactions neither of
us is the original all right we're this
is like greg number seven i'm john
number eight so hey man you will be the
most unique person in this room if you
come on down so thanks for joining us
thanks for getting in there right at the
end of the month
because we love you and it's about time
all right so uh now that you're here you
can never leave and uh we'll see you
next month and every month
from now on
love you buddy
love you don't even know him i love him
he's a false version i love him
no idea deep down in my heart i have a
fixation and i'm running with it i
really appreciate everything you do and
your support and i i'm very appreciative
of that
um i don't yet know you so i can't yet
say the words i love you um i think that
is kind of just a false youtuber thing
to say sometimes when they don't
actually know you i love the support and
i love that you contributed at this tier
but until we get to know you i'm not
quite there at the i love you personally
thing but i love things about you and
things that you have done already
so
that i love so i guess qualities of you
i love
i love you just just love
okay
[Music]